- We have almost run out of time,
but I have one more
story I hope you enjoy.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
If you have stairs in your home,
it tends to be the place
where junk collects.
But as one mama in Tennessee proved,
men have this incredible ability
to just walk past it all.
(transition whooshing)
(mischievous music)
(Kelly laughing)
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
Don't worry.
Her husband was totally
dragged online for that
'cause it's amazing.
We have Laura on the line,
watching on WVLT Knoxville.
What's up, Laura? (laughs)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Hello, Kelly. Thank you
so much for having me.
It's so nice to meet you! I'm
fangirling over here. (laughs)
- Oh, I love it! I'm fangirling.
You are hilarious.
I think a lot of women-
- Oh my god.
- Totally love your video and relate.
Were you surprised by the response?
- I was.
I cannot believe millions
and millions of other moms
out there, other wives out
there resonated with that video.
It's clear that a lot
of other men out there
like to pass things by at
the bottom of the stairs.
It happens constantly.
- My favorite part is when they go,
"Oh, I didn't notice it."
And I'm like, "You"-
(audience laughing)
"You didn't notice the four hurdles
on the way to the room?
Cool. Think we should work on that."
- Right? I'm like-
(Kelly laughing)
(Laura laughing)
- Do you think-
- Yes.
Almost every time, I'm like,
"Did you not see that huge pile of stuff
and the suitcase that you had to move"-
(Kelly laughing)
"To get up the stairs?"
And he said, "What stuff?" every time.
I don't understand.
- It's like magic.
So wait, do you think
he learned his lesson
after you posted this?
- Well, judging by the huge pile of stuff
at the bottom of our stairs right now-
(Kelly laughing)
I would say no.
(Kelly clapping)
But we're still working on it.
You know, it's a new year,
New Year's resolutions.
That's gonna be his New Year's resolution
that I am giving to him, okay? (laughs)
- That is such a great gift to give.
(laughing) I love it.
It's very-
- Right? Right?
- Very, very relatable, Laura.
We love it. It's hilarious.
And I'm liking your post
right now, all right?
(audience clapping)
- Oh, well, thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
It was so nice to meet you, and
I'm just so glad to be here.
- Oh, thank you so much, Laura.
Have such a blessed year.
And everybody, that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor strong mamas like yourself
who hold it down and pick all that crap up
'cause somebody else won't.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Oh my god!
(Kelly laughing)
Thank you, Kelly!
- Absolutely. Thank you, Laura.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jenna Dewan, Sam Jay, Jillian
Michaels, Aoife O'Donovan,
and everyone over at "The Rookie,"
I love y'all so much.
Have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.